what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to the room around of our
weekly series where we cover all the
news and rumors you may have missed over
the course of the week and remember how
much we loved seeing john krasinski as
reed richards and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness well marvel
studios recognized that and disney
recognized that and they are showing us
how much they recognize the amount of
love we had for john krasinski as reed
richards
by not casting him in the fantastic form
so if the rumors are to be believed and
again these are always rumors that come
from a trusted source over at the marvel
studios subreddit or marvel studio
spoilers subreddit apparently marvel
studios is not going forward with read
now this seems to match up with what we
were told previously by sam raimi who
basically said that casting john
krasinski as reed richards in doctor
strange 2 was really more due to fan's
service than anything else but that they
didn't actually have any intention of
casting him as reed for the long term
now if this is true we don't know the
details of it we don't know if john
krasinski was like you know what i'm
cool doing it as a one-off but i don't
really want to do it anymore we don't
know if john krasinski wanted to do it
some more but marvel studios just
decided he wasn't the best fit but
whatever the reason is assuming this
rumor is true john krasinski is not
coming back for reed richards in the mcu
but moving on to our next topic so
remember during the infinity saga the
first 10 years of the marvel cinematic
universe when we were basically
introduced to the concept of thanos and
the infinity stones and we all knew that
it was gonna head into like the infinity
gauntlet story being adapted in movie
form well according to another rumor
that we have which comes from an article
that was written by the illuminati that
the ten rings of shang chi and the
bracelet of miss marvel are gonna be the
multiverse sagas equivalent of the
infinity stones that they're going
towards something that has to do with
the multiverse itself now there is
evidence to show this may be the case
but the evidence that we have is just
scant at best for example the 10 rings
of shanxi we're sending out a signal out
into the ether somewhere and we have no
idea where it was going if it was going
forward in time backward in time some
other part of the universe but the
reality here is that nothing that made
up the ten rings matched anything that
existed in the current records so rumors
abound as to what's going on with the 10
rings and i'm sure this little bit of
news will probably draw more speculation
about what's going on with regards to
the larger shang chi ten rings role
regarding the entire multiverse saga
itself maybe it has to do with kang not
entirely sure but this takes us into
what's really our first piece of news as
opposed to a rumor sony is pushing their
projects back so craven the hunter was
originally supposed to come out on
january 13th in 2023 now it's coming out
october 6th and the funny thing here is
that october 6 is when madame web is
supposed to come out now that comes out
february 16th in 2024 not only that
there is a third untitled spider-man
spin-off that's basically been pushed
back because of craven the hunter and
madame webb being pushed back so here's
the thing to consider about this
i don't know what's going on i have no
idea why this is happening and nobody
really does except the people on the
inside but my question is this is sony
pushing these back because of events
like spider-man beyond spider-verse and
marvel studios having some kind of a
project coming up or is sony doing it
because they need to do reshoots or they
need to rework the script or whatever
the case happens to be it's entirely
possible that it's one or the other the
reality is that marvel studios is
incredibly secretive about the projects
that we're working on we got a whole
bunch of information over at san diego
comic con and then a d23 was basically
confirming things we already knew with
like a couple trailers and like one and
one good announcement and so because of
that like marvel studios is playing it
very hush hush when it comes to anything
they have not already announced
regarding phase five and especially
anything regarding phase six and the
fact that these things are being pushed
back the way they are indicate that it
could very well be something that marvel
studios is working on that's forcing
sony to move these films the other
reason why this may be the case is
because sony doesn't really have a great
track record when it comes to creating
spider-man spin-off films morbius was a
travesty crazy enough my sister said she
loved it
i don't know the important thing here is
that this might be an instance where
sony is going back and reworking the
films in order to basically make a
better product after learning their
lesson from the film morbius i don't
know if that's the case but it's
entirely possible but for all you warner
brothers fans out there who love the
original constantine i got news for you
warner brothers is making a sequel and
here's the funny thing i think the
constantine film is like the rodney
dangerfield of the comic book landscape
it never gets any respect right nobody
ever looks at that movie and it's like
you know what that is that's just a
perfect example of a comic book
character being adapted to a film and it
being done well i loved the original
constantine i thought it was incredibly
well written i thought it was incredibly
well acted and directed here's a great
thing too francis lawrence the guy who
directed the original film he's coming
back and so is keanu reeves i'm so
excited to see this happen and in all
honesty i will say that i think lucifer
in that film was one of the absolute
best depictions of his character not
simply just from like a comic adaptation
but in general the only version of
lucifer that i would say is better than
the one that we saw in constantine
you guessed it the one from the tv show
that version of lucifer was amazing god
i loved that show but at the very least
we thought it was certainly something
worth bringing up because the
constantine film just an amazing movie
and it's fantastic to know that warner
brothers is green lighting a sequel but
moving away from comic book films and
moving into video games for all you
gamer fans out there september 13th
kicked off a week of just insane video
game announcements in law honesty i was
not disappointed once so while sony and
nintendo did give us a whole bunch of
video game announcements we do want to
focus on some of the bigger ones here of
course one of the most notable being
nintendo's announcement of a sequel to
legend of zelda breath of the wild which
is legend of zelda tears of the kingdom
now
i'm gonna be the guy i'm gonna be the
villain in this story
i thought breath of the wild was okay
like i thought it was all right but it
was no majora's mask or ocarina of time
i'm gonna be honest with you guys i'm
sorry i know i sound like a video game
hipster and i'm okay with that but at
the end of the day it's just it was cool
i guess but i just couldn't really get
into it right i just really just
couldn't dig breath of the wild having
said that this by no means indicates
that i'm shutting down tears of the
kingdom but the thing that i really mean
to say here is that when it comes to
this game i am excited to see what it's
going to be like now of course there
were other announcements that did come
out for nintendo for example we're
getting a new fire emblem game for those
of you guys who enjoyed fire emblem
never got into it myself uh we're
getting new content for splatoon 3 and
xenoblade but if i'm gonna be honest
with you guys i think the single biggest
thing that nintendo announced is that a
new pikmin game is gonna be released i
gotta tell you guys i love pikmin oh my
god i love pikmin it's such a fun game
it's just such an amazing game but that
game is currently in development and i
am so excited for when it finishes
because man let me tell you something i
imagine you guys probably never thought
i'd be a fan of like the pikmin series
absolutely i love the pikmin games now
of course on the sony side we got
footage from tekken 8 which is really
cool to see the tekken games have always
just kind of been fun i kind of consider
those to be like the popcorn movie of
video games you just sort of play it or
at least i play to just kind of kill
time i know there's like a huge
community behind tekken and i know that
like the tekken community is super
hardcore that's cool but what we also
got was an announcement for a game that
a lot of people thought we would never
see adapted to the western audience now
this of course is yakuza ishin which i'm
pretty sure i'm pronouncing that
correctly but that was a game from the
ps3 era now it's getting remastered for
the modern era but that was a japanese
game and it was never released here in
the states and people thought that was
never going to happen people never
thought we were going to get that game
here in the states but we are so for
those of you guys who are fans of that
franchise you guys are going to
absolutely love it now as far as i'm
aware
that's the only thing sony announced
right like i didn't announce anything
else
[Music]
oh that's right
that's right
i almost forgot not really they showed
us god of war
ragnarok now let me tell you guys
something man here's the thing when we
got when the the original god of war
trilogy wrapped right when that game was
that game series was done i was like
okay cool this was fun it was really
really interesting then they announced
what was basically a sequel slash
relaunch of the god of war series that
one was phenomenal kratos basically
moving over to face off against like the
norwegian gods and that kind of a thing
that was really really really cool but
in this footage we got to see basically
kratos facing off against thor and i
gotta tell you guys i feel like this
game is like hands down right like hands
down
game of the year i think that's exactly
what's going to happen i think this game
is going to get game of the year it's
going to dominate the gaming charts and
i know that's probably going to kind of
irritate people who aren't necessarily a
fan of that type of game but the reality
here is the god of war series the
original was cool
the last one that we got and this one
it's all it takes the entire gaming
franchise to a whole different level god
of war has never looked or played as
good as it has
right now and i'm excited to see what
ragnarok is going to look like and feel
like because god i'm so
hyped especially with with loki like kid
loki i'm so excited to see how this
whole thing unfolds i still have a
feeling he's going to end up becoming a
bad guy at the end of it all and that
kratos is either going to have to kill
him or he's going to kill kratos and
then they're going to end the god of war
series and that's going to be it right
it'll be like no more games kind of like
how they said no more nathan drake with
uncharted 4 even though we're probably
going gonna get another nathan drake
game somewhere along the line because
nathan drake and uncharted is just a
license to print money for naughty dog
but the thing about this is i'm i'm
super excited about this i am so hyped
for this game it's gonna be one of the
coolest things now for those of you guys
who are old school gamers when i say old
school gamers i mean like
90s gamers og gamers
remember a little video game called
goldeneye
do you remember that game with the
golden gun that was a one-shot kill from
any distance
which pissed off any body that it was
used on while rare the ones who
originally developed it are releasing a
port for the xbox game pass and the
nintendo switch now here's the funny
thing about this this was done
way back when in fact on the xbox 360
there was basically a finished game
right a finished version of goldeneye
with hd graphics online play the whole
nine yards but apparently nintendo got
all pissy because they didn't want that
game to be played on a microsoft console
which kind of makes sense because at
that point in time it was like i feel
like the heat of the console wars so it
made sense that nintendo did that and
ultimately the game was just scrapped
now it was leaked in 2021 and that's how
pretty much anybody who's in the know
knows about it now but the fact that
we're getting an official port of that
game basically for the modern era i'm
excited because i'm interested to see
how the original goldeneye translates
for the modern gamer because back then
right back on the n64 when that game
came out i was all the rage that was the
gateway from multiple people into the
realm of like first person shooters and
there were other great concepts like
that right like perfect dark was a
really cool game i've got i missed
perfect dark so much that game was so
phenomenal but the thing about it is i'm
really excited to see how that
translates for people my age we're
definitely going to play it because it's
going to be nostalgia my question is for
people in this day and age who were
raised with like the newark call of duty
games and were raised with like the
newer halo games and things like that
are they even going to be interested in
a game like goldeneye that's going to be
the really interesting question so i
wouldn't be surprised if social media
just lights up with debates on whether
or not goldeneye holds up after all this
time and we'll find out when it's
released on the nintendo switch and the
xbox game pass but with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this episode to
an end thank you guys for watching as
always if there's any news or rumors
that you missed make sure you leave them
down in the comments and we will catch
you all later
peace